Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge, Folge, Folge, Folge, Folge von Fluch und den Stefan zusammen aus Podcasts Ufo und Rian für euch. Folge 93, herzlich willkommen zu dieser neuen Folge, auch natürlich unsere lieben Hörer auf iTunes, auf... Wir geben stramm! Wer ist hier auf Spotify, wer ist von Spotify gekommen? Zeig mal kurz auf, bitte. Komm mal, wer kommt heute Abend auf Spotify? 30 Prozent, 30 Prozent ungefähr. Oh, in welcher Playlist sind wir denn? Bisschen Crowdwork, bisschen Crowdwork, mal ein bisschen noch von der Bühne runtergehen. Wie flickst du deine Spotify-Playlists? Also bei mir gibt es aktuell, was ein bisschen blöd ist, weil ich seit Jahren alle, die ich gerne gerade höre, in aktuell packe. Mittlerweile sind da 400 Songs drin, die nicht mehr so aktuell sind, meistens. Irgendwann habe ich mir überlegt, ich mache mir für jeden Monat eine neue Playlist. Was ich ein schlaues Prinzip finde. Ein schlaues Prinzip. Empfehle ich jedem, den ich sehe. Aber dann denke ich mir, am Monatsanfang höre ich dann doch immer noch die vom letzten Monat, weil ich dann keine neuen drin habe. Und dann nehme ich doch immer die Songs in die alte Playlist rein. Deshalb habe ich sie, die habe momentan, glaube ich, eine Playlist Juni, die ich immer noch höre, weil ich da immer dann neue Songs reintun. Das ist immer alles schrecklich. Das ist auch scheiße. Aber es ist eine gute App, Spotify. Ja, sehr gut. Wir gehen mit strammen Schritten auf die hundertste Folge zu. Wenn ihr Ideen habt, dann schreibt sie. Wenn ihr denkt, dass wir da irgendwie nichts Besonderes machen oder eine normale, mittelmäßige Folge rausballern. Dann liegt die komplett richtig. Völlig richtig. Wir machen eine ganz normale Folge. Das ist eine Express-Folge. Vielleicht sogar ein bisschen kürzer als sonst. Wir haben tolle News zu verkünden. Florentin hat sich reingehangen, ein Fan hat sich reingehangen, dessen Namen ich leider vergessen habe. Aber es existiert wieder eine Pufopedia! Die Pufopedia ist zurückgekehrt aus den Aschen der Vergessenheit, aus den Nullen und Einsen des Cyberspace. Und wie ein etwas verkümmter Phönix aus der Asche.
Der Phönix ist nicht mehr so cool, also Harry Potter ist er nachher immer prächtiger, genauso prächtig wie davor.
Nee, er ist nicht mehr ganz so cool. Es fehlen die Bilder zum Beispiel.
Satz mit X, Phönix.
Ihr müsst, wenn ihr dieses Hust machen wollt, um einen schlechten Gag zu verdeutlichen,
müsst es möglichst trocken sein.
Mach mal einen schlechten Gag.
Satz mit X, phönix.
Ist nicht so lustig.
Wohingegen wenn?
Satz mit X, phönix.
Ist es lustiger?
Aber wie kriegt man seinen Hals trocken?
Nee, es ist nur wichtig, dass sie nicht tief, sondern möglichst wenig hustet. Möglichst hoch, möglichst vorne im Mund. Ich habe mir darüber nachgedacht, warum das lustiger ist, weil es ist schon wesentlich lustiger. Und ich denke mir, weil man hört, dass der nicht husten musste, sondern nur hustet, weil er die Stimme, die Stille übertönen kann. Wenn jemand dann so oder so Babygeschrei, ist nicht so lustig. Wogegen wenn jemand einfach nur Ja, das Beste, ich bin die beste Reaktion auf den Gag ist, das Niesen. Das ist ja auch oft so so, wir drehen ja manchmal Sketche und ich meine, wir präsentieren uns hier natürlich so als die mega krassen, coolen, souveränen Gagkanonen, aber oft schreibt man auch Sachen und denkt sich so, ist das so lustig? Und dann dreht man den Sketch und dann schaut man den Sketch gemeinsam an und denkt man so, ist das so lustig? Hoffentlich finden die Leute es lustig. Und dann denkt man, okay, der eine Gag in den vier Sketchen, den ich geschrieben habe, und der Gag kommt und... Halt! In die Pointe oder nach. Und dann denkt einfach, wow, danke, es ist besser als nichts. Ja, vor allem mittlerweile nehmen die Pitches auch so überhanden, mittlerweile nehmen wir so Requisiten zur Hand und so. Das wäre auch lustig, macht man niemanden. Aber worauf Stefan eigentlich hinaus wollte. Nee, was ich kurz noch sagen wollte, ich habe heute überlegt, hat man schon mal irgendwie so Beyoncé oder so gesehen, wie sie dann während so einem Konzert irgendwie so ein Körpergeräusch ihr im Weg stand, wie zum Beispiel zu niesen, wo ich stelle mir so vor, sing Ladies, oh, Entschuldigung,
nein, mal weiter singen, als wäre nichts gewesen.
Das sind ja auch Menschen,
das vergisst man ja häufig, aber die müssen ja auch manchmal husten oder gähnen oder so.
Ich stelle mir vor, wenn sie einfach so eine energetische
Single Ladies, oh,
und gähnen dazwischen kommen.
Ich habe letztens, ich schlafe ja kaum noch
eigentlich, ich schlafe immer weniger,
und ich habe wirklich zu früh nachmittags drei Uhr mich mit jemandem unterhalten. Und es war ein recht ernstes Gespräch, so irgendwie bla bla bla ernst und wir verlieren Jobs und müssen Leute gehen lassen. Und ich musste so gähnen. Ach, hier bei uns. Aber ich dachte mir einfach, ich kann jetzt nicht gähnen. Das kommt so falsch rüber, weil es ist drei Uhr nachmittags. Und ich habe echt alles versucht, dieses Gähnen zu drücken. Und es gibt diese Technik, dass man den Mund nicht öffnet beim Gain, habe das so versucht, das war dann eher so ein halbes Übergehen. Verkrampft mega und ich habe mich fast übergeben. Und es war überhaupt nicht funktioniert. Du willst nicht betroffen sein, du willst deinen Job nicht verlieren. Ja, und es ist auch so. Ja, wir gucken natürlich, dass wir Stefan noch im Team behalten können, aber das ist einfach nicht die richtige Reaktion darauf. Das funktioniert einfach nicht. Aber ich verstehe auch gar nicht, warum man gähnen muss, wenn was langweilig ist. Ist das ein Klischee oder hast du wirklich schon mal, oder wird man automatisch müde, wenn man was langweilig ist? Ich habe gähnen auch generell nicht so verstanden, weil gähnen ist doch, wenn man Sauerstoff braucht, oder nicht? Genau, wenn der Körper zu... Löwen gähnen ja auch, aber die entscheiden ja nicht, plötzlich nie mehr zu atmen oder sowas. Ich glaube es ist einfach, wenn der Körper so weit runterfährt mit der Aktivität, dass man auch zu wenig atmet und dann irgendwann denkt so, oh shit, jetzt haben wir es ein bisschen übertrieben gerade mit dem Runterfahren des Mechanismus, des Organismus. Jetzt muss man ein bisschen nachhundert, dann gähnt man. Und dann fährt man wieder langsam hoch, oder was? Das ist auch so, wenn man müde wird, dann fährt der Körper schon so halb runter, aber dann wenn man dann nochmal irgendwie ein Glas sich holt, dann ... Du meinst, das Gähnen ist das, wie man merkt, das BANG-Geräusch, wenn man wieder hochfährt. Ja, so ein bisschen, ja. So kann man es ganz gut, ganz gut verdeutlichen. Hochfahrtgeräusch. Worauf Stefan aber eigentlich hinaus wollte, ist, die Pufopedia ist back. Don't call it a comeback. Die Pufopedia ist weg. Mal gucken, wie lange es jetzt noch dauert, bis es von russischen Sexbots überlaufen wird. Aber sie ist wieder online. Bringen Sie nicht auf die Idee, die russischen Sexbots. Pufopedia.info. Info. Da kamen ganz viele Daten und wir haben dem Daten geschickt und er hat uns Daten geschickt. Und dann kam es hin und her Datenaustausch und daraus entstand jetzt dieses neue Paket. Pufopedia.info ist jetzt aktiv, und zwar hat unser MVP des Jahres eigentlich, Hörer des Jahres, Mike, hat es geschafft, die Pufopedia wieder ein bisschen auszugraben. Und die Sache ist jetzt die, es konnten einige Artikel gerettet werden, auch einige Bilder, könnt ihr mal kurz selber gucken auf Pufopedia.info. Und das Problem ist, viele alte Textversatzstücke wurden gerettet, aber die konnten noch nicht sortiert werden. Deswegen gibt es auf der Seite... Oft vielen Satzenden, das ist wie so ein Lückentext. Genau, es macht noch Spaß. Stefan wurde geboren in... Ja, und dann müsst ihr einfügen. Dann könnt ihr mal das ein bisschen selbst testen. Und da ist dann dieser Schulterzug-Emoji. Wie viel wisst ihr über uns? Und das heißt, ihr könnt auf pufopedia.info unter alle Seiten anzeigen, gibt es auch so verschiedene Einträge, alte Texte, alte Texte. Wenn ihr mal irgendwie Bock habt und Freizeit habt und einfach mal sagt so, ach schön, die Sonne geht gerade unter, ich sitze auf meinem Balkon mit meinem Laptop, schlürfe ein Latte-Chai und denke mir einfach, oh, jetzt habe ich ein bisschen tun, was gemeinnütziges zu tun, schaut mal da vorbei bei alte Texte und da könnt ihr mal gucken, ob ihr da alte Satzfragmente noch oder Textfragmente zusammenfinden könnt und neue Artikel erstellt oder irgendwie das Ganze als gemeinschaftliches Projekt wieder aufzubauen. Und denkt dran, es ist ein Comedy-Projekt. Ihr könnt auch mal Folgen, die in der Zukunft liegen, könnt ihr mal einfach betexten. Es ist ein Gacken, was da passiert. Ihr könnt auch über Karibus gerne was schreiben. Wir lieben Karibus, ihr liebt Karibus, schreibt einfach mal ein bisschen, was euch in den Sinn kommt. Das kann eine grosse Gag-Sammlung sein. Apropos Wikipedia. Ich habe mich ein bisschen auf Apropos Karibus geschreut. Ich auch, aber es ist leider nicht möglich. Ich wohne in der WG und ich bin ja der schlechteste Mitbewohner aller Zeiten. Das heißt auch, dass ich keinen Schlüssel zum Briefkasten zum Beispiel, keine Ahnung. Das heißt, die Post lehrt immer jemand anders und dann die Post, die für mich ist, legt er dann immer zu mir vor die Tür. Das he, auch wenn man so ein neuer Mitbewohner eingeführt wird, so spricht auf gar keinen Fall mit Flur und ihm. Wenn ihr ihn ansprecht, lasst ihn zuerst sprechen, guckt ihm nicht in die Augen und legt ihm die Post so vor die Tür. Ja, und es ist dann so, das heißt, meine Mitbewohner kriegen so ein bisschen mit, was ich so für Post bekomme, in der Regel gar nichts. Aber ich denke mir so, was ist die coolste Post, die man bekommen kann? Stadt Köln ist cool, Polizei auf jeden Fall, aber das sind in der Regel Strafzettel oder zu schnell gefahren, das ist dann eigentlich eher Dussel. Mord, irgendwie so Erpresserbriefe sind cool, Liebesbriefe sind auf eine gewisse Art cool, wenn irgendwie so ein bisschen so Erotik noch mit drin ist, so ein BH oder sowas. Zeitschriftenabonnements sind cool. Richtig cool, aber ich habe diese Woche den vielleicht coolsten Brief bekommen, den man bekommen kann, und zwar haben meine Mitbewohner aus dem Briefkasten gefischt einen Brief von Wikipedia. Das ist ja geil, das ist wirklich cool, weil du einen Beitrag jetzt hast, oder was? Und jetzt ist die Frage. Aber warum haben die denn deine Adresse? Ja, viele Fragen bilden sich jetzt gerade. Viele Fragen. Und wo man sich denkt, so als Mitwohner so, Moment mal, Wikipedia, also Wikipedia ist ja einerseits das coolste, was es gibt und das dulligste, weil da kann jeder Trottel alles reinschreiben, was man will. Aber Wikipedia ist schon cool. Und nächstes Jahr, ein Brief von Wikipedia? Noch cooler wäre, glaube ich, IMDb. So, ich habe noch nie einen Brief von einer Website bekommen. Nee. Stell dir mal vor, du kriegst einen Brief von Instagram, wo du einfach denkst, Moment mal.
Aber jetzt, was war denn da drin?
Ja, jetzt überleg mal.
Ja, also ich glaube, du hast einen Artikel und er wird, weil er nicht gebraucht wird, weil dich niemand kennt, wieder gelöscht und die wollten sich vorsorglich bei dir entschuldigen.
Weil wir bedanken für die schöne Zeit, die wir hatten auf Wikipedia.
Und ich dachte tatsächlich auch, okay, cool, ich habe anscheinend einen Wikipedia-Artikel und die wollen anscheinend verifizieren, so von wegen, hey, stimmt das? Wo ich mir aber auch das... Was sollen die verifizieren? Das war mein erstes... Gibt es sie? Ja, gibt es sie wirklich? Oder so, stimmt es, dass sie 1804 geboren wurden? Auch da, dass sie einen Brief an alle Florentin Wills bestimmt schreiben gerade. Haben sie wirklich vier Arme? Irgendjemand irgendwie, Death Warrior 66 hat das reingeschrieben, stimmt das? Ich stelle mir vor, das ist wie so ein Multiple-Choice-Test, wo drinsteht einfach so, wo du einfach ein paar Fragen über dich beantworten sollst. So, wie viele Eltern hast du wirklich? Sind deine Eltern wirklich Brüder? Sind deine Eltern wirklich zwei Männer? Und dann so ganz viele freie Zeilen für Trivia, so, schreiben sie doch mal was. Kreuz ein Bild von dir an. Wer sind sie? Genau, und da dachte ich mir, ah, okay, krass, wusste ich gar nicht, dass Wikipedia sich so viel Mühe gibt, da irgendwie ihre Artikel zu verifizieren. Krass, ich glaube, wie die Story enden könnte, du hast gespendet und es ist ein Dankeschön, dass du gespendet hast. Exakt das war's. Ehrlich ist es? Ja, exakt das ist es. Exakt das war's. Exakt das war's. Ich habe 15 Euro an Wikipedia gespendet und sie haben mir so eine Bestätigung geschickt, dass sie es von der Steuer absetzen kann. Das war's. Und ich glaube, ich war selten so enttäuscht. Das ist mega gut. Mir an dem Tag, wo ich dachte, krass, Wikipedia, cool, wie sieht denn so ein Brief von Wikipedia aus, wie so eine Wikipedia-Seite, lustig und nichts. Einfach nur so ein ganz maschinell abgefälltes Ding, das hat mir scheiße. Aber vor meinen Mitbewohnern stehe ich immer noch als der da, der fucking Post von Wikipedia bekommen hat, was mega cool ist.
Ja, ich kriege jetzt neuerdings immer Post von SOS Kinderdörfern, weil es gab damals diese Eisbacke.
Hilfe, hilf uns, hilf! SOS, das drückt so eine Notsituation aus, wo ich mir denke, so hallo, euch gibt es seit 15 Jahren, wie schlecht kann es euch geben. Ein Treffen daran haben wir, holy shit, Kinderdörfer. Ja, genau. Wir haben massive Brottensohle, Mayday, Mayday, Kinderdörfer. Ich kriege keine Luft mehr, Kinderdörfer, sowas in der Art. Dafür will ich spenden, wo ich sage, okay, die brauchen wirklich Hilfe. Shit goes wrong. Ja, genau. Ja, gut, also ich kriege Briefe davon, weil ich damals gab da diese Ice Bucket Challenge und ich habe dann wieder das Video von mir gemacht, habe aber nie was gespendet. Dann fühlte ich mir das so ein, so, du bist ein ganz schönes Arschloch. Wie, du hast ein Video, ach stimmt, aber nicht öffentlich, ne? Nee, nur an die Leute, die mich, nur ein paar Leute. Ich habe dich, glaube ich, du bist einer der Menschen, die ich exkludet habe. Ich glaube, so ein paar Promin ich mir hatte, immer Facebook-Teilienz und die einfach nicht, die sie nicht sehen sollen. Und dann habe ich dann vor einem halben Jahr bis ab dann gespendet, weil ich dachte, du hast nie gespendet, das ist mir einfach so eingefallen. Und dann habe ich aber nicht an dieses ASMR gespendet, was auch immer das war. AOL aus Versehen. Sondern an SOS Kinderdörfer. Und weil ich dachte, die haben es bestimmt nötig, ich meine, dieen schließlich SOS Kinderdörfer. Und dann habe ich dann die gespendet und jetzt kriege ich immer Briefe von denen. Die spammen einen richtig zu damit. Deswegen ist meine Botschaft an euch, long story short, spendet nicht SOS Kinderdörfer. Ey, das ist so dumm. Das ist doch das Letzte. Du spendest doch, um ein gutes Gewissen zu haben, um diese scheiß verhungernden Kinder von dir wegzudrücken. So, ja, hier habt ihr euer Geld, viel Spaß in Afrika, ciao. Das Letzte, was du willst, ist, noch tiefer in den Charity-Projekt einbezogen zu werden. Ja, und vor allem sollten die ja nicht mich erreichen, weil ich bin ja jemand, der potenziell spendet und das wird ja normal tut. Die sollten doch lieber Leute erreichen, die noch nicht spenden. Ey, was die sagen müssten ist so, pass mal auf, du spendest uns jetzt 100 Euro und du wirst in deinem gesamten Leben nie wieder irgendwas von SOS-Könnenreifen haben. Du kriegst noch eine VR-Brille, wo unsere Logos gegen McDonalds ausgetauscht werden. Genau, oder so lustige Gifs oder so von Katzen. Perfekt. Oder noch besser, du zahlst uns 1000 Euro und du kriegst nichts von uns, sondern Amnesty International holen wir dir auch aus deinem Briefkasten raus, die fangen wir ab. Vom Briefmann fangen wir alle Briefe von Amnesty International ab. Wir canceln auch noch andere Charities. Das finde ich gut. Die Leute bestrafen dich dafür, dass du spendest. Das ist doch genau das Falsche. Das finde ich gut. Wir müssen ganz kurz noch mal über ein Thema sprechen, was mich die Woche sehr beschäftigt hat. Und ich weiß Florentin auch. Florentin hat mich vielleicht schon gemerkt, gerade in der Folge, hat seinen Humor verloren.
Ja, das stimmt.
Er hat diese Woche, hat er und weißt du, wir beide, seit Jahren versuchen wir, Comedy wieder salonfähig zu machen, wir versuchen den Gag zu finden, wo er gerade uns anbietet und vor die Pornos zu versenken.
Wir hatten Komparsen da, ein püffiges Kerlchen, der für den Sketch, wo es im Lieferunternehmen geht,
in unseren Autorenraum kommt
und sagt... Er hat einen Kostüm an.
In einem Kostüm. Er hat ein Kostüm an von einem Lieferant.
Richtig, hatte so ein bisschen Tracking-Besicht,
alles cool, Kostüm, kam rein und hat gesagt,
hat die wer was bestellt und grinst es an
und tatsächlich haben alle so ein bisschen
gelacht, weiß nicht, der beste Gag, okay,
und Florentin sagt, nee, nee, ich habe schon gegessen.
Und der Raum war still. Der junge Mann, der den Gag gemacht hat, wusste auch nicht, wie er reagieren sollte, hat uns gesagt, ja, okay, hat die Tür wieder zugemacht und ist gegangen. Und dann haben wir gesagt, Flontien, das war ein Scherz und du bist aus allen Wolken gefallen. Völlig zu Recht, und es tut mir bis heute weh.
Es hat mir wehgetan in dem Moment, es hat mich verletzt,
es hatte ich eine Gänsehaut am ganzen Körper. Das war furchtbar, der Moment. Was geht denn dir vor? Das Problem ist, wir hatten Essen bestellt an dem Tag. Und das Essen war in so kleinen Boxen in der Küche. Und ich habe schon gesehen, nach dem Essen eine Box ist noch übrig. Und ich dachte mir, okay, jetzt schiebe ich mir später noch mal eine schöne zweite Portion rein.
Und dann kommt dieser Typ und fragt,
hat jemand Essen bestellt?
Und ich dachte, er bezieht sich auf dieses übrig gebliebene Essen, von wegen,
braucht noch jemand was zu essen oder kann ich das essen?
Weil ich wusste nicht, ob die Komparsen auch
Essen bekommen oder nicht. Und deswegen dachte ich,
und dann habe ich gesagt so, nee, nee, ich habe schon
meins gegessen. Und das war,
ich bin vollkommen in die Gagfalle gelaufen, weil er wirklich so, hat jemand Essen bestellt und ich so, nee, nee, ich habe schon meins gegessen. Und das war, ich bin vollkommen in die Gagfalle gelaufen, weil er wirklich so, hat er mit Essen bestellt. Und ich so, nee, danke, ich habe schon gegessen. Und er ist extra, extra, hat er extra die Tür zu unserem Autorenbüro aufgemacht. Du bist wie das Date, wo man merkt, der hat keinen Humor, ich gehe sofort, ich bin sofort weg, ciao. Vor allem, er hatte kein weiteres Anliegen, außer den Gag zu machen. Er hat nur die Tür aufgemacht, um den Gag zu machen, und hat reingerufen und es kam nichts zurück. Und wirklich, die Tür ging zu und alle gucken mich eigentlich so, hä, Moment, und dann Aber du willst auch weinen, zusammen gesagt. Aber das fand ich lustig. Jemand, dem ich unterstelle, zu viele Gags zu machen, auch in Situationen, wo es nicht unbedingt angebracht ist, jemand erzählt gerade, ich hab meine Mutter gestern verloren und Florian macht den Gag. Hahaha, die Vette oder was? Nein, das ist Florian, das weiß ich nicht, sorry. Nicht wirklich ein Gag. Mir ist nichts besseres eingefallen. Und jemand, der zu viele Gags macht und dann im Raum sitzt, wo jemand extra für den Gag reinkommt und du sagst, ich habe schon gegessen, der arme Mann, wie fühlt er sich denn jetzt? Vor allem, da muss er die Tür wieder zumachen und da muss er den ganzen Weg wieder zur Küche gehen, für den er den Gag dachte, okay, der Gag ist es wert, dass ich jetzt ein bisschen Zeit aufwende, zu dem Raum gehen, den Gag machen, wenn wir jetzt zurückkommen. Ja, also Komparsen sind ja ein merkwürdiger Schlagmenschen. Welcher Kompars war es eigentlich mit dem einen Bein? Keine Ahnung, das ist aber auch eine ganz merkwürdige Situation, dass wir irgendwann mal erfahren haben, dass das ist wie so ein Ratespiel, so einer der letzten hundert Menschen, mit denen du heute Kontakt hattest, hatte nur ein Bein. Hatte nur eine Augenbraue. Welcher ist es? Und du so, Moment mal, was, was, was? Wer war es denn? Ich weiß es bis heute nicht genau, aber ich habe nur erfahren, dass einer der Komparsen, mit dem wir schon gedreht haben, nur ein Bein hatte. Und ihr könnt euch jetzt nochmal alle gute Arbeitssketsche anschauen. Der in dem, wo der keine Beine hatte. Nee, nee, das stimmt nicht.
Dem wurden die versteckt.
Du, wir sagen dir nicht, wo deine Beine sind.
Och jetzt Leute, bitte, kommt schon.
Nein, sagen wir dir nicht.
Komparsen sind merkwürdige Leute, die
in der Regel oft den ganzen Tag alleine in der Küche
rumsitzen. Ganz kurz, sorry.
Aber was ist das für ein Gag mit, ich hab deine
Nase eigentlich. Sorry, aber müsste man nicht auch anders reagieren als Kind? Irgendwie so, what? Du hast meine Nase, bist du verrückt? So hat man das erste Mal auch reagiert. Wer war der erste Mensch, der diesen Gag gemacht hat? Und wie hat der reagiert? Vor allem, stell dir mal vor, du bist so einer Feier und dann machst du diesen Gag zum ersten Mal und da rumstehen Kumpels, was sagt dir denn, was du da gerade machst für einen Gag? Ja. Es ist ein unüblicher Witz. Wer war die erste Person, die Geburtstag gefeiert hat? Hatten wir so schon mal? Na, der sich seinen Geburtstag gemerkt hat. Der war auch so ein, ähm, ganz kurz mal, Leute, kann ich ganz kurz mal alle eure Aufmerksamkeit haben? Kommt mal kurz zusammen, Louis, lass mal den Säbelzahntiger ganz kurz hinten vor, kommt mal alle her.
So, folgendes, 16. Mai sagt euch jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht so viel der heutige Tag, aber, ich weiß nicht, wer sich noch daran erinnert, aber...
Die Sonne stand schon mal genau so gerade am Himmel.
Und zu dem Zeitpunkt wurde ich geboren.
Okay, ähm, ja, was, soll man dir jetzt was geben, oder? Ich stand schon mal genau so gerade am Himmel. Und zu dem Zeitpunkt wurde ich geboren. Okay.
Ja, was?
Sollen wir dir jetzt was geben?
Ja, schon.
Aber ich meine,
ich habe gerade das Bedürfnis, dir was zu geben,
was du auspusten kannst oder so.
Möchtest du so ein kleines Gebäck,
wo wir dir den Seelzante hier da hinschenken?
Einfach so.
Und schon war es die kosmische Konstante. Die Engel kamen vom Himmel herab. Happy Birthday. Sieht man das eigentlich? In wie vielen Kulturen singt man Happy Birthday? Ist das das bekannteste Song der Welt? Warner hat die Rechte an Happy Birthday, lustigerweise. Echt? Und deswegen sieht man das nie in Filmen. Achtet mal drauf, man sieht nie in Filmen, die man Happy Birthday singt. Na bestimmt. Nein, weil die Rechte unfassbar teuer sind. Das ist jetzt wieder so ein Amigo-Effekt oder so, dass man denkt, man hätte das ganz oft in Filmen. Wie heißt der Effekt? Mandela-Effekt. Dass man denkt, man hätte das ganz oft gesehen. Amigo-Effekt. Der Freund-Effekt. Man ist besser mit jemandem, den man befreundet, als man denkt. Der Amigo-Effekt. Aber es gibt doch bestimmt zu Szenen, wo Leute die Kerzen ausblassen. Ja, aber dann singen die vielleicht. Hoch soll leben. Hoch! Würdest du den Geburtstag feiern, wenn das nicht gesellschaftlich vorgegeben wäre? Auf gar keinen Fall. Oder? Überhaupt nicht. Gar nicht. Ich hätte auch nicht mitgezählt, glaube ich. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Ich habe tatsächlich, ich komme, ich hatte letztens auf einer Busfahrt richtiges Problem herauszufinden, welches Jahr wir haben, ob 17 oder 18. Ich konnte es mir nicht sagen. Und ich dachte mir, Moment, wie alt bin ich denn? Wie alt bin ich denn? Bin ich 25? Ich hätte nämlich auch mal eine... Ich völlig verlungern in Zeit und Raum. Falls ihr noch mal Bock habt, die Reisepass-Storyline weiterzuführen. Yes! Es ist wieder der Zeitpunkt. Ich brauchte dafür meine Geburtsurkunde. Und ich dachte mir, jetzt kommt endlich raus, ob das meine Eltern sind. So, ob das wirklich meine Eltern sind. Ich hatte meine Geburtsurkunde in der Hand. Und mir ist aufge aufgefallen, ich habe mich wissen, ich habe willig geguckt, wann wurde ich geboren,
wer sind meine Eltern. Obwohl man
keinen rationalen Grund hat, nachzugucken,
ob das stimmt alles und wann du
geboren bist, man glaubt das ja einfach.
Man nimmt das als gegeben hin.
Aber wenn man so ein Dokument sieht, wo das nochmal beglaubigt
ist, hilft das einem schon.
Wenn du jetzt heute erfahren würdest,
deine Eltern wären nicht deine echten Eltern,
und man würde sagen, ah, hier, die beiden sind die echten Eltern. Meinst du, du hättest noch Kontakt weiterhin mit deinen alten Eltern?
Ich würde sofort zu meinen neuen Eltern gehen, einfach weil ich die Abwechslung cool finde. So einen Tapetenwechsel einfach mal. So, okay, mein Vater ist jetzt schwarz, yeah, geil, wie cool ist das denn? Ist er Rapper? Aber würde man sich trotzdem ab und zu noch treffen und sagen so, das war schon eine merkwürdige Nummer, die ihr für 25 Jahre durchgezogen habt, aber trotzdem, schönen Urlaub war es schon. Ich will auch nicht wissen, wie viele dieser Storys es gibt, dass man einfach Kinder verwechselt hat. Das ist glaube ich schon noch relativ häufig der Fall. Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Weil man das Band bekommt direkt meinst du? Das war nicht der Grund, warum du das nicht vorstellen kannst. Sieh mal mit deinem Band, ey. Jeden zweiten Tag über sein neues ... Wenn man das Band bekommt. Weißt du, du hast echt die das wirklich wildeste Hobbys der Welt. Du baust ATSs aus Lego und überlegst dir neue Systeme, wie man Kinder auseinanderhalten kann. Und immer bei Brainstormings, ja, ich habe eine Idee zum Thema Kinder ... Nee, ich meine jetzt eher so Sketche, Stefan. Ja, aber wenn du das Band direkt nach der Geburt anbringst, ja, ist nicht unser, können wir jetzt nichts, nee, aber Orange für Mädchen und Blaue für Jungs, wenn man da sich, Stefan, wie gesagt, wir kommen hier nicht weiter einfach. Wir machen doch Mittagspause gerade, kannst du ganz kurz die Fresse halten einfach. So läuft ungefähr jedes. Ganz kurzer Kommentar, den wir bekommen haben von Gnomi, möchte ich kurz vorlesen, weil ich fand es ein bisschen creepy und zwar hat er geschrieben, niemand hat das jemals so gesagt, oh, ich fand es ein bisschen creepy.
Der hat geschrieben, Gnomi schreibt, was Florentin da als Gag raushaut bezüglich der Realitäts-Lags, hast du nicht manchmal das Gefühl, wenn du Häuserfassaden siehst, du denkst, dahinter ist doch nichts, hat einen durchaus ernsten Hintergrund.
Seit längerem wird schon die Frage diskutiert, ob unsere Realität nicht etwa das Ergebnis einer Computersimulation ist. Und in diesem Fall würde, wie in einem Computerspiel, nicht die ganze Zeit alles berechnet werden, sondern nur die Teile der Welt, die gerade angeschaut werden. Hier ein Paper, in dem beschrieben wird, wie darüber die Simulationshypothese theoretisch überprüft werden könnte. Ich habe den nicht gelesen, aber es klingt interessant. Schaut mal in die Kommentare zur letzten Folge. Natürlich liest du diesen einen Kommentar vor, wo jemand sagt, oh, diese Story, diesen Gag, den Florentin da nebenbei raus, ist eigentlich eine Mega- es ist ein Genie, Florentin ist ein Genie. Ich bin ein bisschen neidisch auf deine Reisepass-Storyline, da muss ich ganz ehrlich sein. Deswegen will ich meine eigene Storyline haben. Ich will meine Realitätshypothese hier in Storyline. Aber das ist doch schon eine ewig alte, uralte Theorie, dass wir in einer Computersimulation leben. Und die oft sagen, Leute, können wir nicht, weil wir leben in einer Unendlichkeit. Das Universum ist unendlich groß. Ja, aber woher wissen wir das denn? Und Computerprogramme können keine Unendlichkeit herstellen. Wenn das so wäre, gäbe es eine Endlichkeit, was auch spannend wäre. Ja, aber gut, du kannst ja auch ein Computerspiel bauen, das potenziell unendlich ist. Du kannst ja einfach sagen, je weiter die Figur Richtung Osten läuft, desto mehr generierst du da einfach wieder Häuser und Bäume und Flüsse und machst halt dadurch Zufallsalgorithmen und baust du immer eine neue Map auf. Dann kannst du auch unendlich lange Lauf gehen, bis halt dein Prozessor irgendwann aufgibt und der Festweite voll ist. Ich glaube manchmal, dass ich der einzige Mensch bin, der existiert und alle anderen wurden mir geschickt, um mir so eine Heldenreise. Aber ich bin selber nur der Sidekick in meiner eigenen Heldenreise. Das ist ja die Frage, da gibt es ja die philosophische Theorie, aber dann denkt man sich mal, ja, aber warum läuft es dann so scheiße, wenn ich der Einzige bin, warum bin ich denn nicht cooler, also wenn ich der Held in meiner eigenen Welt bin, warum ist es dann so lame? Ja, das sagt mir jetzt wie jemand, der nicht echt ist, lustigerweise. Ach so. Also ich habe ja das Gefühl, dass es bergauf geht, deswegen, also vielleicht ist ja, also nach Aristoteles müsste am Ende erstmal so, ich glaube, wahrscheinlich ein Alpaka überaka über den Hof. Es tut mir leid, mein ADHS wird gerade extrem befeuert. Einfach mal ist in diesem Raum, es passiert nicht viel. Wir haben uns zurückgezogen in so eine weisse Hohlkehle, es passiert nicht viel, aber dann läuft plötzlich einfach ein Alpaka am Fenster vorbei. Die sind so kuschelig, diese Alpakas, das ist unfassbar. Die haben so große Augen, aber die wollen leider nicht angefasst werden. Naja, am Hals schon, ich habe die am Hals ein bisschen geknuddelt. Ja, das Ding ist, wenn es so Tiere gäbe, die dann auch knuddeln wollen, die dann auch so touchy sind und einmal ankommen, das werden glaube ich, die werden sofort zum Tode verurteilt. Ja, vor allem die Situation war, diese Alpakas für den Dreh, werden die Alpakas verwendet, da kamen diese Alpaka-Bauern oder diese Alpaka-Besitzer oder Domteure oder was auch immer, kommen wir mal an, ein ganz merkwürdiger Schlag von Menschen. Liebe Grüße an der Stelle mal. Liebe Grüße an die Frau, die richtig vor unserem Fenster steht. Und die kamen an mit so einem Lieferwagen, und da waren zwei Alpakas drin, die so in so Mini-Gehegen in diesem Auto waren. Und dann wurden die rausgenommen, da wurde eine Alpaka rausgenommen. Und in dem Moment, in dem das eine Alpaka das Auto verlassen hatte, das andere Alpaka so, ööööö. Und dann meinte die Besitzerin so, ah ja, Alpaka sind Herdentiere, die mögen das nicht alleine zu sein. Wo ich mir denke so, wie hast du das denn jetzt interpretiert? Das kann auch genau sein, dass der rausgeht und so, endlich ist der weg, der Arsch, hau ab! Und du so, ja, das sind Herdentiere, die mögen nicht alleine. Bring mir ein Bier mit! Ja genau, dann werden die völlig falsch verstanden. Vielleicht ist das die schlimmste Vorstellung für mich, dass Tiere immer missverstanden werden und
so, keine Ahnung, so Schweine
ja, ne,
eigentlich ganz anders behandelt werden wollen,
aber man denkt immer, ah ja, Kühe wollen
auf die Weide, Kühe wollen das,
weil die springen so lustig rum, wenn man die auf die Kühe
kommt, aber die sagen, vielleicht haben die Todesqualen.
Kühe lieben es, geschlachtet zu werden.
Die können sich nichts besseres vorstellen, als den Gedanken daran zu sterben. Double Steakhouse im King-Menü. Bitte melk mich nicht mit der Hand, nein, mit diesen Drahtreisszwecken, Automaten. Ich mag dieses kalte Gefühl an meinem Euter. Saug mich aus, saug mich leer, Maschine. Ja klar. Ey, manchmal denke ich mir, fuck, man würde ich gerne auch Milch produzieren können. Ja, ich freue mich, wie sich das anfühlt. Ich hätte mir so eine Vorrichtung, so ein Strohhalm hätte ich mir da hingebaut. Ey, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass so eine Frau, die laktiert, nicht auch mal sich schön eingibt. So nebenbei im Bus. Wenn jemand himkt, oder? Wie ist das denn so? Kann man die auch dann steif schlagen, die Milch? Klar, ist ja nur Milch, oder? Das ist nur normale Milch. Kann man damit auch. Ja, ich glaube schon. Ich glaube, du hast schon mal Rührei gegessen, wo das keine Milch war, wo du jetzt glaubst. Haha, die ist vom Tier. Wie geil ist es, dass ein eigenes Snack dabei zu haben? Vor allem, das ist ja nicht so wie Spucke, sage ich mal so. Aber machen Mütter ihren Kindern Rührei dann mit Müttermilch? In Rührei ist, wo ist denn Milch überhaupt mit Rührei? Ich mache immer Milch in Rührei. In Rührei? Klar. Echt? So ein Spritzer, Spritzer, Striezen. Das habe ich noch nie gehört. Ich habe immer nur Mineralwasser in Rührei gehört, damit es so ein bisschen fluffy ist. Was? Damit die Kohlsache so ein bisschen Fluffigkeit ausmacht. Das ist Lächer. Du führst ein lächerliches Leben. Das ist das einzige, was ich aus dem Physikunterricht mitgenommen habe, dass unser Physiklehrer so mal nebenbei, um die Gruppe so ein bisschen aufzulockern, gesagt hat, übrigens der perfekte Pfannkuchen kleiner Schuss Mineralwasser, damit der so lockerer wird. Und das habe ich, also Heisenberg, so unschämfliche Relation habe ich alles vergessen, die Stromfunktion, alles vergessen, aber das habe ich mir gemerkt. Ich finde es so geil, wenn plötzlich im Kapitel 5 im Physikbuch plötzlich ist, dass wir in der Computersimulation leben, und dann macht man mir Kapitel 6 weiter als Gaps, das ist die Theorie nicht, und dann alle kurz, Moment, Moment, Moment, was wir letzte Woche da besprochen haben. Genau, oder so, man liest es und dann blättert man wieder zurück und Moment mal, da stand doch gerade die Theorie. Das ist nämlich der Punkt, wenn wir in einer Computersimulation leben würden, würde die nicht automatisch jede Bestrebungen unterdrücken, dass die Subjekte herausfinden, dass sie in einer Computersimulation leben? Ja, oder ist es genau das Ziel? Es ist Westworlds Ziel, dass sie das verstehen, dass sie das durchstehen, sozusagen. Oder sind wir gerade das Resultat dessen, sind wir die Mutation, die aus dem Computerspiel heraus entstanden ist? Aber überleg mal, das ist nämlich Elon Musk hat es mal so beschrieben, glaube ich jetzt einfach, ich habe ihn irgendein Prominenten gerade. Aber guck mal, GTA früher, wie sah ich früher GTA aus? Das ist als Spiel identifiziert. Mittlerweile wird es immer besser, immer besser. Mittlerweile kannst du schon Open-World-Städte einfach preisen und Dinge machen und Missionen machen und es sieht schon mega echt aus und es sieht fast fotorealistisch aus. Jetzt spring mal, nicht nur 200, 300, sondern 1000 Jahre in die Zukunft, wie ein Spiel aussieht und wie Leute reagieren können mit Artificial Intelligence. Was ist da noch möglich? Und natürlich ist davon, wenn man das mal weiterführt in Richtung Unendlich, ist da natürlich irgendwann eine Simulation, wo Leben entsteht und miteinander spiegelt und so. Also vielleicht sind wir gerade nur so NSCs in einem Computerspiel von irgendeinem... Aber was schon lange mutiert ist. Von Trump, von Donald Trump vielleicht. Ja, das glaube ich nicht. Der gerade irgendwie seinen Missionsziel erfüllt hat, Achievement Unlock. Nein, nein, nein. Oder wir sind halt, wir sind nur so künstliche Intelligenzen, die halt an so einer Welt immer besser werden sollten. Und sobald wir die Welt durchgespielt haben, sobald wir festgestellt haben, dass wir in der Matrix sind,
kommen wir aus der virtuellen Realität raus und kommen in die nächste, sodass wir immer besser werden.
Wie so Bakterien, die unter immer widrigeren Umständen leben müssen, um dann immer stärker zu werden.
Ich stelle mir vor, wir wachen irgendwann auf, weil wir das durchgespielt haben,
und dann werden wir wieder an so ein Schreibtisch gesetzt, wo wir gute Arbeit machen müssen.
Irgendwie so was, dass wir wieder von vorne anfangen müssen. Das wäre auch anstrengend, oder?
Dieses Computersimulationsding ist immer so ein bisschen schwierig, weil man weiß ja nicht, welche Möglichkeiten der Programmierer hat. Ob der jetzt einfach sagen kann, okay, stopp, zwei Wochen zurückspielen und noch mehr Zeit zurückspielen. Aber da kannst du sagen, physikalische Gesetze. Ja, aber du kannst in GTA kann auch der Entwickler einfach sagen, stopp, letzter Spielstand, noch mal reloaden und dann geht's noch mal weiter. Ohne dass die Figuren im Spiel das wissen. Ja, aber du kannst davon ausgehen, dass gewisse Gesetzmäßigkeiten dabei genau immer bleiben, dass man sich, dass auch der Programmierer sich an die Gesetzmäßigkeiten der Natur halten muss, weil die nach seinem Ebenbild erschaffen wurden. Die physikalischen Gesetze in GTA sind ja auch eher nicht zu unseren. Also man kann, ich glaube, da habe ich mal sowas gelesen, aber das wird auch kompletter Bullshit, und ich schiebe mir einfach weiter in mein Duplo rein und entschuldige. Für alle, die sich weiter dafür interessieren, schaut mal den Kommentar von Gnomi an, danke. Wir lesen die Kommentare, so ist es nicht? Du lesst die alle. Nulli. Mir ist es auch gefallen, neulich. Du kennst ja die Szene aus Harry Potter mit Ollivander. Ja, Zauberstab, die Zauberstäbe suchen euch aus.
Müssen die dir dann bezahlen?
Weil, was ein Scheissladen.
Stell dir mal vor,
du bist beim Lidl,
aber die Avocados suchen sich die Besitzer aus und dann ist es
einfach scheiße. Und du meinst, du bist
schlecht dran, weil du so einen teuren kriegst?
Oder kosten die alle gleich viel?
Ja geil, mich hat jetzt der ausgesucht
mit dem Goldkern,
Platinkern für 16.000
und du bist schlecht dran, weil du so einen teuren kriegst. Oder kosten die eine gleich viel? Ja, geil, mich hat jetzt der ausgesucht mit dem Goldkern, Platinkern für 16.000 Euro, geil, kann ich nicht den mit der Eulenfehler haben für 40 Cent? Ja, das ist ein Problem. Wie viele Leute der schon in den Bankrott getrieben hat, Oliwander, einfach so ... Upsala, der eine Milliarde Dollar. Noch eine Hypothek, sorry, Frau Grangel. Ich kann nichts dafür, weil die Zauberthema sucht.
Ich dachte aber eher, warum müssen die das bezahlen?
Also warum müssen die das überhaupt bezahlen?
Und müssen sich Oliver die ganze Zeit einfach draufzahlen, weil er da einen Laden hat, wo die Gegenstände sich die Kunden aussuchen.
Ja, vor allem der baut die ja selber, ne?
Weiß ich nicht. Also da ist dann so eine Phoenix-Feder in einem drin und so.
Und meinst du, das ist so wie so ein McDonalds-Mitarbeiter, dass man auch mal so in einen zu rein lunzt und dann so, was ist denn in dem drin? Ja, wie so Subway. Der hat dich ausgesucht. Oder man kann sich das zusammenstellen, wie so Subway. Kann auch sein. Harry Potter ist eh ein komisches Universum, oder? Weil überleg mal, die können, warum haben die keine Handys? Weil die könnten noch schneller kommunizieren als mit Eulen. Das ist doch auch strange alles. Das ist alles mega strange. Und wie uncool wäre die ganze Geschichte gewesen, wenn alle miteinander vernetzt wären. So Waffen, warum schalten die sich, okay, vielen Dank für den Zauberspaß, hier kommt das Militär und greift einfach Voldemort. Harry konnte doch nur Voldemort dann besiegen, weil die den gleichen Zauberstab hatten, das war ein Problem. und dann mussten die die irgendwie wechseln und dann konnte der den umbringen.
Warum nicht einfach so eine schöne Knarre, einfach schön kurz so ein Snipergewehr, auf, Voldemort, Voldemort ist dead. Ja, Prämissen, Prämissen. Ich weiß es nicht. Ja, wie lange hast du Zeit eigentlich? Nicht mehr lange, fünf Minuten vielleicht noch, nochmal einen Gag. Komm, wir machen noch einen Gag. Nochmal einen Gag. Hast gesehen, ich habe eine Bomberjacke jetzt, ne? Und ich komme mir vor wie so eine Sitcom-Episode, weil ich steige mich so rein und ich bin einfach ein anderer Mensch mit dieser Bomberjacke. Und ich komme mir auch so vor, als ob mich andere anders wahrnehmen damit, weil ich habe jetzt eine Original-Bombersjacke und ich bin da so stolz drauf, dass ich diese Jacke besitze jetzt, weil das auch so eine, von der Air Force hat die so eine Seriennummer und sowas, das ist eine Original-Bomber-Jacke. Ich glaube, dass du einfach langsam anfängst, Seinfeld-Episoden nachzuspielen. Ja, ohne Scheiß, aber das dachte ich mir auch, es gibt nämlich diese Seinfeld-Episode, wo er diese Jacke hat, und dann geht die einfach kaputt durch den Regen, aber er ist auch bis dahin einfach ein anderer Mensch. Genauso komme ich mir vor, mittlerweile sind meine Probleme auch so Sitcom-Probleme, so einfach zu lösende, weil ich glaube, Ja, allem und dann versuchst du nochmal, ja Moment mal, wie ging es denn dann weiter in der Folge und dann findest du raus, dass die Folge nie existiert hat. Und dann so... Und dann ich eigentlich in einer Sitcom lebe und nicht in einer Computer-Simulation. Ja. Aber das ist schon strange. Also vor allem, weil Leute in einer Sitcom, sind die glücklicher oder unglücklicher als wir? Weil die haben, theoretisch haben die keine Probleme, die haben nur so Sitcom-Probleme. Die haben Probleme, die in mindestens 23 Minuten wieder gelöst werden. Eben, genau, die haben keine Probleme. Also wenn man überlegt, wenn man am Anfang eine Sitcom mal anhält, auf Stop drückt und dann überlegt, wie könnte er das jetzt lösen, liegt es immer auf der Hand. Und meistens ist es auch das Ergebnis am Ende der Folge. Aber das ist so spannend, haben die angenommen, dass man würde so leben und wenn man dann trauriger, weil plötzlich jedes Problem zum krassesten Problem wird, oder wenn man glücklicher, weil man eigentlich keine krassen Probleme hat. Also wie kann man sich Sitcom-Karater vorstellen? Ich glaube, die sind schon sehr lustig, weil bei mir über jeden Gag jemand lachen würde. Lachen die ja nicht. Naja, aber Studiolacher oder sowas oder Klatschen, wenn man auftritt, ich glaube, das hat schon einen positiven Effekt auf deine Psyche, dass du denkst so, hm, ganz schön wenig Leute auf dieser Strasse hier, komisch, warum läuft niemand über diese Strasse hier? Und warum dieses Publikum? Aber ich glaube, es ist auch anstrengend. Ich bin mir vor, der guckt beim Masturbieren plötzlich so ein Publikum dazu einfach. Und dann lachen die nicht. So wie bei Truman Show, das finde ich die coolste Szene, wo der dann ausbrechen will aus der Welt und dann kommt so ein Stau, entsteht dann plötzlich, dann sagt der, okay, wir brauchen so einen Stau, dann kommen wir Stau und dann kann er nicht weiterfahren so. So können so eine Computerrealität funktionieren, dass immer wenn du dran kommst, weil zum Beispiel ich habe jetzt nicht auf diesen Link geklickt von Gnomi. Also existiert der Inhaltwelt noch gar nicht. Vielleicht, oder halt der kein anderer Programmierer, der mir zugewiesen ist, hat jetzt gesagt so, ah ding, die Wäsche ist fertig, und dann ah okay, dann vergesse ich den Link und dann. Aber hätte ich auf den Link geklickt, hätte ich vielleicht rausfinden können, was damit, vielleicht ist dieses Paper nicht lesbar. Vielleicht sind Staus einfach nur, probiert mal, ob ihr zu Hause den Link öffnen könnt. Schaut mal, ob ihr es schafft, den ihr zu klicken. Bitte verschwindet nicht, werdet nicht aufgewärkt oder so, wir brauchen jeden Hörer und jede Spende. Patreon.com. Oder Paypal. Aber es wäre cool halt, einfach, nee, Paypal nicht, wir haben kein Paypal, sorry. Ja, das ist ein ganz schwieriges Thema. Aber ich finde, jeder Stau, finde ich schon eine coolere Vorstellung von Stau, wenn der einfach nur den Weg verhindert, weil gerade die Landschaft noch nicht geladen ist. Es würde auch die Verkehrsdurchsagen ein bisschen interessanter machen. Auf der A8 versucht schon wieder jemand aus der Show auszubrechen. Bitte haben Sie Geduld dafür, die Einsatzkräfte sind schon wieder. Auf der A83 ist man wieder auf die Idee gekommen, dass wir in einer Simulation leben. Oh Mann, Sie, wir lernen auch nicht dazu. Wir haben Stau. Schönes Wochenende bedanken Sie sich bei Subjekt Nummer A844614612.
Und jetzt kommt der Song, den Sie alle so lieben, 01111011111 vom Lieblingsinterpreten 0111111.
Ich tue jeden Tag dasselbe und denke nicht nach, was morgen ist.
Mein Leben ist perfekt, ich stelle keine Fragen.
Je tiefer meine Fragen, desto größere Probleme, also lasse ich es lieber sein und dann bin ich doch glücklich. Oder man macht so einen Podcast, in dem die Leute darüber reden, wie sinnlos es ist, sich über solche Computersimulationen wahrzuwerden, damit die Leute denken so, ah okay, lustig, das ist alles nur ein Witz, damit sie gar nicht ernsthaft auf die Idee kommen. Was für eine geile Simulation, wenn diese Simulation sowas wie Family Guy erschafft.
Das ist schon geil. Dann haben wir schon eine coole Simulation. Und deswegen will ich auch lieber das gucken, einfach Fernsehen gucken, als wieder darüber Gedanken zu machen, ob ich möglicherweise der einzige bin, der existiert oder in einer Simulation lebe. Selbst wenn man das rausfinden würde, wüsste man ja nicht, ob das auch wieder eine Simulation ist. Man kann ja schon in der zwölften Unterstufe der Simulation sein, weil irgendwann fangen so Bakterien auch an, Häuser zu bauen und so Ritterturniere zu veranstalten. Und wir können auch nicht mit ... Ja gut, da geht es wieder von vorne los. Oder wir leben sogar in einer Simulation, einer Simulation, einer Simulation. Weil wenn es so was möglich ist, dann leben wir wahrscheinlich in der n-fachten Simulation. Ja, aber das fände ich interessant, sobald es möglich ist, so eigene Zivilisationen zu bauen, so wie Lisa Simpson, die in so einem Schimmel-Joghurt dann irgendwann so eine eigene Welt erschaffen hat und dann konnte man mit dem Motoskop zugucken. Oder Rick, der um sein Raumschiff anzutreiben, halt diese Welt erschaffen hat, wo sie denken, dass sie Strom produzieren müssen, um zu überleben. Ey, es gibt so viel coolere Sachen als das Podcast, Ufo.
Es gibt auch so viel coolere Sachen, als sich darüber Gedanken zu machen, worüber wir uns gerade Gedanken machen.
Ey, man könnte sich einfach Rick and Morty nochmal anschauen, anstatt diesen Podcast zu hören.
Bald kommt die dritte Staffel raus. Das ist geil.
War es auch schon wieder für diese Woche vom Podcast, Ufo Willen, Angeln, Steffen, Witzel.
Ja, weil Föhr und ihn weg muss.
Ich muss weg, ich muss nach Hamburg, es tut mir leid.
Ansonsten wünsche ich euch eine schöne Woche.
Ich wünsche euch eine schöne Woche, macht's gut.
Tschüss.
Und wir heben ab.